welcome to
AKO
Mano remember the convenience store how
are you you're the only other human I've
ever seen here oh I don't like your face
what what wait wait wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait all right my dudes see
you around see around
that was a little reminder this is akko
mono I think it's made by the same
person that made that game with these
scares in it
how are you
um you don't need to know anything about
that game to know this game
it's just by the same person and people
say it's very scary
here this is your punishment
I just got here why am I being punished
you're going to go on a little
exploration it's gonna be a lot of fun
I don't know about you but I don't
really consider punishments to be fun
this is what you get for being close to
him
now don't you think of escaping
better not run
okay I'm a little confused
but whatever you whoa
oh no
hi hello ah hello hi will you hurry what
better not run
what do you mean what what do I do I'm
gonna explore in here
okay
I'll uh
I'll be back
thanks Pals
You're such good friends to me
I appreciate you and all that you do
for me
it was this an abandoned school or
something
okay
better find another way in I'm assuming
I have a video camera which is why my
eyeballs are freaking out the way they
are
I made it in
but why oh no
oh no
I don't like this
I don't like this at all
oh
no
hello what a weird bathroom
well if it isn't the rumored handsome
transfer student
that's me
one weekend and you're already the talk
of the school so can you tell me what
happened to you
not the most talkative are you well I
knew that that's what everyone says
about you I can probably get what
you can probably guess that Kobayashi
and his group got to you
they love being at the center of
attention you see and you took that spot
albeit unwillingly I would say judging
by your personality those kids have been
a thorn in my side but they keep getting
away with it as you may already know
Kobayashi is the principles in the Sun
and he's quite clever I think I have a
solution though I bought a mini tape
recorder and if you their new Target can
get evidence of what they do to you the
principal will have no choice but to act
great
that's great
that's great
why red paper why
paper why red paper why what is that
planks why
ah interesting
okay I have an old key now
very wonderful I hate it
foreign
I don't like that there's a mechanic for
partially opening doors that suggests to
me that
it's not going to go good for me missing
girl poster missing girl poster right
don't like that either
don't like any of this
I don't like being here I don't like
wandering around I don't like exploring
horrible things I don't like boarded
events
I don't like hiding in a closet
I don't like any of this
that means I'm gonna need to hide from
things from something and I don't like
hiding from something
some dark spirit is holding the door
you know if I could just detect that I
think I'll just run away you know if I
can tell that a dark spirit is holding a
door close I'd just leave the building
why am I doing this
oh
don't like
I don't like
I don't like I don't want to get to lay
the land oh my God oh my God oh my God
hello crowbar that's handy
rap something I bet I can take down some
planks now but I don't know why I would
want that
why would I want that why would I ever
want that oh
is this a good idea this is not a good
idea this is a bad idea
it was a bad idea this is a bad idea
this is what you would call a bad idea
why would I do this why would I do that
why would I have done that why would I
do that
drawer you mean to tell me there are
probably things in drawers oh boy well
who needs this can I drop it there we go
ah
that's better I feel good now
yeah I feel great
oh
what
what ah don't touch that
okay so what uh
why are you talking to me
I don't know
I don't understand
this is weird
I'm confused
hello recording Too Perfect
just press the red button and uh oh
start and stop this recording I'm
already recording this conversation as
we speak you can press this button to
rewind and this to play back everything
I just said in case you forget one final
thing don't get caught trying to record
them always keep it in a safe place so
it won't fall off you down
well here just keep it on your person if
you change your mind also in case you
have anything bothering but don't want
to tell me in person just recorded on
that and I'll be happy to help I am your
counselor after all thanks
sorry Nakajima this will probably be the
first and last recording I make on this
device
what Kobayashi said wasn't too far away
from the truth anyway I deserve what
came to me and besides it's not as bad
as what I usually get
what do you usually get I don't know I
don't know I don't know who these people
are I don't know why I'm here I don't
know why I got too close to that guy or
whatever
Anatomy nose
why would I have an anatomy note I don't
want an anatomy of nose until I know
that I'm going need an anatomy ow that's
bad idea
wait bug
hey stop that no I got an anatomy nose
you don't want to mess with me
oh why would you do that oh my ass
freaking weirdo I don't know how much
health I have or if I have health or if
I'll die if I take too many womps from a
centipede in the hall oh God cables why
I don't have enough inventory
[Music]
oh
what is it what is it what is floating
ominously towards me
oh God why what is with what is that all
about
okay so I can't be in the dark
that's good to know ah dark is bad
foreign
that's weird that's
that's weird okay that's
that's weird
I can't look that way uh
um
help help
me is that trumpet it's a pipe Oh I
thought it was nothing spider killer
spray would that work on a centimped too
many things too many things
planks okay this might be helpful I
don't know I don't know I don't know I
kind of seem to go everywhere I don't
know what my objective is what is my
objective I don't know I don't know what
I'm whoa no no
I think that means that the thing is uh
the the person in the red robe is coming
for me oh God
wait this is the this is where the
anatomy nose is
yeah
and then the grunting and the groaning
this is uncomfy oh God please not
um
okay
I think I got away for now
oh another bathroom how many goddamn
bathrooms are there
oh another an orange paper okay so I had
a red paper and now an orange paper but
still not enough inventory to do
anything about it
oh boy oh
now it's open why what is that what is
that what am I looking at what is that
what is that what it what
hello that's weird uh
can I leave can I leave I would love to
leave I would love leaving uh
strategy right now is to run screaming
into the dark with my lighter and hope
that I don't die
here the skittering
okay there's weird portals everywhere I
are they gonna walk through that is that
how they get through the building or
something
because I can't do nothing about that
not working not working
that's what oh no
why oh
okay the cables
I should have got ah I gotta go back
through everything so that I can go
okay this is a problem I'm very slow I'm
gonna Crouch
okay thank you uh you suck you suck man
you suck
okay you suck a lot all right that
centipede's probably crawling this way
down here yep right on cue I'm just
gonna go right past oh no I'm not
don't come this way
idiot
stupid okay so I think I dropped down
here what I'm going to do is I'm gonna
drop the Crowbar uh because I've opened
up a couple entrances and I I guess I
could
do with losing it for now I don't know
if I grab the cables
drop this you can pick up that
get this out you're ready to bolt it
Corner oh no oh no oh no oh God oh God
oh no
don't
do that don't who's in there
oh God no I don't wanna
oh acid who pissed acid who who pissed
acid can I bucket that wow
[Music]
I don't know I don't care I don't care I
don't care damn it close
I don't know I don't know where am I I
don't know this is a different than it
was energy drink that'll probably make
me run faster I guess
what is that recording eight I don't
have time for eight are you kidding me
you think I could just stand around for
eight
oh I'm outside
oh kerosene pump
oh I don't have the padlock key anymore
uh
I'm doomed
it's oh that's
bad whoa hey whoa there is no need I
wish I had an energy drink oh man you
could not do anything
hello hello what is that squat toilet
was it full of poop is it poop is that
poop I poop wait did I just go in a
circle
oh wow this sucks
um
[Music]
oh no oh no
I don't feel so good I have wires
I don't know what these do I mean
okay so
um
all right
so hmm
damn I'm gonna take a breather not that
I'm scared but I'm gonna take a breather
okay so what I need to do differently
this time is I need to create Escape
rounds and that's I like of course my
first time through this not gonna be too
great you know I'm not gonna do a great
job you know I'm not gonna have a great
time but I don't know what the red paper
is for
for something but I don't really know
what it is but what I'm going to do is
I'm going to uh Scout the area I've got
a better lay of the land even though I
said that I didn't want to know the lay
of the land but I have a better lay of
the land which means that it's gonna
help me
to create all the Escape Routes I need
and then you know from there be able to
escape you know that's how Escape Routes
work
so I'm assuming that they eventually can
come down this way some dark spirit is
holding that I'm guessing that might be
the start of it once that door opens
it's kind of game over
either way I'm gonna leave that there
because I can be right there I'm just
gonna go down to the farthest area that
I can for this see what is there if
maybe there was
some kind of a
another
thing okay so this is completely blocked
off what I need to do to start all this
is go into that freaking thing with the
thing but that does go somewhere else I
don't know where that goes it's not good
but you know it's there oh wait wasn't
there one in the back bathroom
[Music]
didn't I see one in here
there is
so I'm gonna unlock this one and I'm
then I'm gonna unplank the other one and
then at least I have these two here as
Escape Routes
okay
okay
so I'm gonna go in this one with this
because I don't remember where this
links up
but I'm building the map in my mind
oh Indigo paper I don't
know what that's for
I'm gonna go drop the paper off so that
I have it in the main lobby and that way
it's retrievable
right
like that
why did that close
okay
so I'm Gonna Keep it oh
[Music]
huh okay I'm Gonna Keep it right there
so that I can go get this paper I don't
know what it's for but I have a funny
feeling that I'm gonna need pretty much
everything here eventually
grab this paper drop it off I don't know
why but I have it
[Music]
this game
legitimately scared me but like all
these horror games once you get the
mechanics down
see easy
peasy I imagine that eventually you
wouldn't need the lighter you could do
this all blind if you really wanted to
but right now it just makes me feel
comfortable
makes me feel very safe it's quiet
why
oh oh
it circles back okay that's good to know
okay so that circles back there I'm
guessing of the electrical wires must
control the fans so that allows me to
get by those somehow I don't know how
maybe then I can crowbar it I don't know
I think I just need to open up all the
entrances that's basically it that's all
I need to do and avoid dropping down
anywhere until I'm ready for that where
do you go ah no you dropped down that's
not what I want right now I want to just
play very methodical
very methodical
okay an anatomy knows I don't know why
I really don't know why it must be for
something but I'll just keep it in the
lobby area that goes up and around and
then drops down this goes here undo
these
okay
that's good
all right
I don't remember where this is I think
it isn't this the men's room in the
beginning this might be back to the
lobby again
so I've got multiple Lobby
and then spider killer spray
oh no I hate that I hate that I hate
that that I hate that that that that
that that that is that thing
no it's not oh [ __ ] no no
oh God
oh god oh no no I'm not dealing with it
now I'm not dealing with it right now
I hate it
I hate it
all this something about this game is
just no big no
I don't know where I'm going I lost at
the moment wait no I needed to come down
I came down already didn't I didn't I
oh I did not oh where does that drop I
don't know
I don't know I I don't know oh here okay
well [ __ ]
I guess
[Music]
that's the bathroom I think that is the
bathroom I was just in I'm going I'm
going for it
are you here yes me you yes
okay
no this is the bathroom
ah this is the bathroom at the beginning
I think
yes yes okay drop this crowbar for now I
don't really need the lighter unless I'm
going down in the different areas
but right now I have the electrical wire
so I can get by here without dying
oh
no no no no no no I'm not doing it not
doing it not doing it no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no
oh no are we gooping oh God we're
gooping oh we're gooped up
oh God we're gooped
we're full on gooped
we're full on gooped my Bros
I just gotta get in the electrical room
oh my God
second floor first floor what does this
mean
oh God
I don't know what these do first floor
uh I don't know
I don't know
I guess the fans Maybe
I can't I can't tell
I hear some gooping there's like some
goopage
okay we're good
I'm gonna go check to see if like the
fans here are on or off
because I should be on the first floor
right now I do believe oh it is okay
interesting so uh
oh I walk right through
[Music]
weird Okay weird very weird well why
hello hi it's been a while since I
talked to another human being what
you took the red paper didn't you poor
girl what what's that you want me to
help you I don't know what are your main
red paper I don't know well then you
have to toss me a coin
huh
what
energy drink huh
I don't have a coin what do you mean
coin I don't have any coins
what are you talking about
was there another fan on the first floor
let me check around this way I don't
think there was but maybe I'm wrong nah
not here anyway
there used to be another paper here what
does that mean it's where I took the red
paper I think I don't know what that's
about but I I really don't I have all
these papers but I don't have any coins
oh
no oh no why would you do that oh God
this was the worst place to go oh I
don't have an escape here oh I'm dead
I'm doomed I'm damned
please
no
okay
I think I'm okay
okay I guess the red goop on the walls
means that eventually they're gonna come
through
if you hang around there long enough I
gotta do the second floor once I think
unless these are
I don't think they would be they seem up
nah they're not
okay I need to go back to the switch and
hit the second floor fans
oh frick why why
that's fine
okay no why why why what is what what is
it I don't see it what is happening why
nothing
you crazy am I crazy
am I crazy
I'm crazy
second floor I'm going all right screw
it screw it don't care don't care I
don't care I don't care I don't care I
don't care oh funny enough I don't care
I don't care I'm gonna go see what's
behind those fans this game seems too
complicated I don't know what I'm doing
half the time I don't know where I'm
going I don't know why I'm here I just
wanted to talk to a boy
can't any High School in Japan just be
normal
oh crap
gunning it
I'm on the open be open be open here oh
ah there's two that's why there were two
switches on there okay so that's good
there's only a total of three fans but
this is gonna take a lot of back to oh
textures oh God wait oh no oh no wait no
no come on oh I don't have time
where am I I don't know where am I oh
hate hate hate hate close close hate
close
oh I have ah where's my nose
oh well I never thought I would touch
this thing again recording my own voice
is slightly embarrassing to say the
least let's get straight to the point my
father beats me and lately it's getting
worse I understand if you don't believe
me you probably already know that he is
highly respectful politician I assure
you however that this is true he makes
it a point and never lies this damn
slogan for crying out loud but why does
any of that matter when he just bends
the truth to his own convenience anyway
you don't have to hear from me after all
I have the evidence
okay well I don't know what it does
bring me seven
seven I just found one nose what does
this game want pack of C's what do you
want from me game
it's ridiculous
oh God
oh what is that oh okay well that's
handy that that's right there
now I could hold it
all right whatever I have a nose so
that's good
Wham there you go pal
I don't know if there's someone crawling
around here or what
I'm concerned
oh well that's a
that's open now that's good
you hit the other fan
okay and now I'm gonna go back in
I go to the thing
and I'm gonna go up to the through the
other fan and then I'm gonna see what's
over there and then when it's too much
for my fragile mind to handle I will
exit the game I have alt f4 I have an
alt f4 out of a game in Terror for a
while not that I'm scared not that this
is terrifying but for some reason I'm
put on edge and I don't like that so I'm
going to do whatever it takes to avoid
exacerbating that feeling uh-oh
oh no
huh just like Indiana Jones
no take your time go on take your time
it's okay thank you
all right
carrying on
okay good
where does this go
oh even higher this probably goes to
that third floor uh hate hate hate hate
hate it I hate it
I hate it I hate this I hate all of it
oh my God I hate this what is with this
school
this makes no sense
none of this makes any sense how is this
sensible this isn't it's not
where's where am I what am I doing here
why am I here why why is any of this the
way that it is
oh
hey have you heard of recent suicide
weren't you in charge of that kid yeah
it was the one ah okay he was found dead
in the exact same way his whole body cut
up can you believe that moose said that
still having concerned uh
uh
you okay no no no one's okay here no
one's okay
oh my God
oh my god
oh succeeds
oh my God no
please I don't want it
oh my God
I'm in here you can't kill me I'm safe
[Music]
what now
what now
what now
[Music]
I don't know if I can do this I don't
know if I can do this
my fragile disposition
very tender disposition it is
oh what is enough food dude
what's in the food I don't know what
that is
oh great
great
I think I'm just gonna run for it oh I'm
in here now I'm oh oh my god oh I'm
gonna book it I'm booking I'm booking I
am booking
booking uh uh I saw that what was that
I'm booking I am booking
I'm booking
I'm booking
I booked
I'm going to book
hey today's menu oh sick oh tight ah
fishing rod what is that for I don't
know
oh good in it you know I'm just gonna
Slug it here we go yoink oh that heals
me I'm gonna slap a Talisman on the next
person that comes at me [ __ ] bring it
might be one of those banishing Talisman
or something I don't know
you should come here and show your back
yeah you know your feeble back I don't
like that
ugh
foreign
okay
that's uncomfortable
I don't need to use this right now are
you sure about that
okay
oh wow that's a pretty good knife oh guy
what do you do you take this and one of
these
foreign
[Music]
well
this seems like a very complex game with
a lot of mechanics and I don't
understand what I'm doing and I don't
know where I'm supposed to go so I'm
gonna call that one as uh I'm gonna put
I'm going to shelve this one I'm gonna
shove it in there if you guys want me to
play more of it I'll play more of it but
only if it's a really strong surge in
demand
so thank you everybody so much for
watching if you want more scary games
I've got them links in the description
big playlist all scare games plus
there's probably a few scary games
lingering around on my channel that um
aren't in that playlist actually there's
thousands of them so go check them out I
got a lot of videos on my channel
like over five thousand so thank you
plenty of other games besides just
wanted to check out if you
want this one against me this one really
gets me so thank you and
as always I will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
[Music]